a ten-centimeter high balancing act
these high heels are the creations of
Swedish designer named Yosef II he calls
them Melania there is something very
unusual about these shoes apart from the
way they look they are made from
polyamide and have come straight from
the printer I haven't any idea about the
2d printing and then I wanna only
actually luster dust problem and find a
way to make that organic shape and then
I find the new technology the 2d
printing at the terrific thing is very
very high technology that they can that
you can make the new shapes the designer
who's originally from Iran believes that
3d technology is the future of shoe
production first the shoe is digitally
drafted the design is then optimized by
3d printing specialists mikkel eriksen
special software transforms the model
into impulses that control the printer
the shoe is created on a platform that
slowly moves down layer by layer the
process isn't very different from that
of a regular printer but instead of ink
it uses liquid plastic which is then
hardened with a UV laser it builds my
lair and it's a very very thin layer yes
a safer yeah it's thinner actually so 16
microns oh yeah that's 16 thousandth of
a millimeter which explains why the
printing process takes up to 40 hours
producing a single shoe costs around
1,500 euros
perhaps in a in a future anyone could
come with a shoe and that we print out I
think the the the technique and the
machines are quite expensive today so we
have to develop the machines towards a
faster way to to print this month the
shoe is printed in a soft protective
synthetic casing which has to be removed
name your selfies original design is
starting to emerge as a strong durable
polyamide shoe the material makes a shoe
you can wear though it does take some
getting used to actually this year's
need to differ of course I want to put
some different material together and
softer material inside and and and the
harder material in the outside but the
technology is not in so fit well just
now a growing number of fashion
designers are experimenting with 3d
printers here's some designs by janina a
line from britain and marla merchant
IRA's fan up and from the netherlands
showcased her designs at the paris auto
auto show in july she created the
collection together with designer REM
koolhaas when I design I think sweetie i
even don't like to sketch because
sketching is two-dimensional everything
for me it's like if our logical step to
work with 3d printing this was the first
time that we did that it's really
because the technology has moved so
rapidly that we were you know we were
now willing to to go for that back to
Stockholm nehemiah cephus Malone iya has
made it to museums including the
renowned Victoria and Albert Museum in
London the model who wore the shoes is
quite taken by them they actually are
really comfortable they fit the the foot
perfect and they're really unique and
that's why i love them they actually
they actually are nice nium yosef he is
currently working on a new 3d printed
model at the moment his shoes cost
thousands of euros but he expects prices
to fall in the future working in an idea
to to being that to to the customer that
you can take it you can buy it or use it
that kind of design in easier and then
you can come to my to my shop at my
store and scan your body and an order
your your your your shoes or your
accessories very easily who knows in
just a few years we may be adding our
very own self print to choose to our
shop board collection